[Música]
[Aplausos]
colombia ir a la segunda vuelta
presidencial en dos semanas y las
encuestas continúan cambiando con los
últimos sondeos le dan una estrecha
victoria a gustavo petro sobre rodolfo
hernández pero nada está dicho en estos
comicios donde no hay candidatos de los
partidos tradicionales
petroleras extranjeras que habían dejado
de operar en venezuela podrán volver a
hacer entre ellas están la eni que es
italiana y la española repsol que
detuvieron sus producciones como
consecuencia de las sanciones impuestas
por eeuu tenemos análisis
jefes de estado y de gobierno se reúnen
desde este lunes en los ángeles eeuu
para una nueva edición de la cumbre de
las américas el evento inicia con
polémica y también con incertidumbre
ante la ausencia de varios mandatarios
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos en colombia porque
la carrera por la presidencia comienza
en su recta final a dos semanas del
balotaje las encuestas ponen a los
candidatos muy cerca uno del otro aunque
gustavo petro parece repuntar sobre el
rodolfo hernández según los últimos
sondeos muchos podrían votar en blanco
al no sentirse representados por ninguna
de las dos opciones
andrés granadillo nos amplia frente a
frente están los candidatos a la
presidencia de colombia según una
encuesta revelada por el centro nacional
de consultoría para el medio colombiano
semana el izquierdista gustavo petro
alcanzaría la presidencia con el 44,9
por ciento mientras que el populista
rodolfo hernández obtendría el 41% de
los votos los indecisos quienes podrían
definir el resultado son el 94 por
ciento pero estos números contrastan con
los que salieron tras la primera vuelta
el primero de junio daban hernández como
ganador con el 41% mientras petro
conseguía el 39% un resultado visto como
un empate técnico las movidas políticas
última semana podrían ser las causantes
de estas variaciones el ex candidato del
centro sergio fajardo quien sacó el 4
por ciento de los votos de la primera
vuelta intentó hacer acercamientos con
hernández para adherir a su candidatura
pero no hubo éxito en la semana una
organización feminista hizo un llamado a
un debate a los dos candidatos al que
solo asistió petro la inasistencia le
echa leña al fuego a la campaña de
hernández quien ha sido acusado de ser
misógino debido a declaraciones contra
las mujeres en medios de comunicación
gustavo petro no se encuentra tampoco en
una posición de ventaja ya que debe
convencer a los votantes de los terceros
y cuartos puestos en las elecciones de
la primera vuelta
tanto los votos que tuvo sergio fajardo
que no fue más del 4 por ciento o algo
más del 4 por ciento de la elección como
más del 20 por ciento que obtuvo
federico gutiérrez muchos de esos se van
a ir al voto en blanco o simplemente se
van a abstener
precisamente el voto en blanco en la
última encuesta representa el 3% y
podría ser un catalizador de la
polarización donde muchos electores no
votaría ni por la izquierda en cabeza de
gustavo petro ni por el populismo de
rodolfo hernández vamos a venezuela
empresas petroleras que habían detenido
su producción en el país caribeño como
consecuencia de las sanciones impuestas
por eeuu ahora podrán volver a operar
así lo anunció el presidente nicolás
maduro quien celebró la decisión de
washington de entregar nuevamente las
licencias entre las beneficiadas se
encuentran la norteamericana chevron la
italiana eni y la española repsol que
todavía no se han pronunciado al
respecto previamente hablamos con
santiago arroyo director del ccc energy
consultor especializado en petrolíferos
y experto en energías quien nos contó si
eso podría representar un alivio para
los países europeos en medio de la
crisis energética y su intento por dejar
de de hidrocarburos rusos y en efecto se
trata de un quiero pensar que es un
proyecto piloto para compensar las
sanciones impuestas a rusia y obviamente
el espacio que deja el producto ruso en
el mercado internacional
a causa de estas estas sanciones que
impone la comunidad internacional
derivado de el conflicto con ucrania en
este caso pues estamos viendo que quizás
estamos viendo una especie de pilotaje
de un programa con la finalidad de ir
paulatinamente
sustituyendo el consumo de productos
petrolíferos de gas por parte de europa
con
productos de países que anteriormente
estaban siendo baneados por parte de la
comunidad internacional específicamente
estados arroyo también nos dio su
opinión sobre el acercamiento de
washington y caracas en materia
económica mientras el gobierno de maduro
fue descartado de la cumbre de las
américas en eeuu
bueno en este sentido vamos a tomar en
consideración que son medidas
extraordinarias ante tiempos
extraordinarios que se están viviendo y
finalmente los beneficiarios en este
caso son la comunidad europea y las
empresas de donde hay a mano y
finalmente si bien es cierto existe la
intervención de una empresa de carácter
norteamericano como el chevrón en este
caso también vamos a considerar que está
de las tres empresas señaladas es la más
cauta todavía en ir avanzando con este
con este plan o con este programa y vaya
en las relaciones se van a ir mejorando
atendiendo al avance que también exista
en esto en estos proyectos y ver la la
reacción que tenga el estado venezolano
con con relación a estas actividades
realmente esto es algo un elemento muy
positivo y bueno vamos a estar viendo
muy atentos qué es lo que va a suceder
en los próximos meses con este con estos
proyectos
y a propósito de la cumbre de las
américas en eeuu la ciudad de los
ángeles acoge desde este lunes y hasta
el próximo viernes 10 de junio una nueva
edición del encuentro jefes de estado y
de gobierno del continente se reunirán
para tratar diversos temas en materia
económica migración y libre mercado pero
el evento llega marcado por la polémica
que genera la ausencia de líderes de
países que no fueron invitados como
venezuela y nicaragua y de otros
mandatarios que en una muestra de
solidaridad con estas naciones
anunciaron que tampoco participarían del
encuentro
y en otras noticias de eeuu a este fin
de semana el país fue sacudido por
varios tiroteos uno fue registrado en un
club nocturno de chattanooga en
tennessee donde al menos tres personas
perdieron la vida en la noche del sábado
al domingo solo horas antes se dieron
otros hechos similares uno en phoenix
arizona donde una adolescente falleció y
ocho personas fueron lesionadas en un
centro comercial y otro en una zona de
varias de filadelfia donde tres personas
murieron y otras doce resultaron heridas
el presidente de perú pedro castillo fue
llamado a declarar en una investigación
que tiene en contra por presunta
corrupción la fiscalía peruana citó al
mandatario para el 13 de junio castillo
puede acudir al despacho fiscal o rendir
testimonio desde el palacio de gobierno
el ente investigador está indagando
desde abril las denuncias de
irregularidades en la construcción del
puente de tarata en la amazonía del país
la fiscalía considera que existió una
organización criminal ligada al actual
ejecutivo de castillo pero el presidente
lo niega
seguimos ahí en perú durante la
presidencia de alberto fujimori se
llevaron a cabo violaciones a los
derechos humanos por los cuales años
después fue condenado el exmandatario
familiares de las víctimas desaparecidas
en esa nación suramericana no pierden la
esperanza de encontrar a sus restos
rafael pérez nos cuenta más en la
siguiente historia
un ritual a la pachamama para que
devuelva a los cuerpos de los
desaparecidos en la masacre de la
cantuta
un caso de los años 90 en el perú de
fujimori nueve estudiantes y un profesor
fueron secuestrados acusados de ser
guerrilleros y posteriormente masacrados
e incinerados y enterrados en este punto
apartado el dolor no se ha borrado del
corazón de sus familiares a ojalá que
dios quiera que nos encontramos aún que
sea un pedazo de mí por ser realmente
que no no estoy con no estoy bien cuando
no le encuentro a mí
las excavaciones fueron iniciadas por la
fiscalía peruana allí un grupo de
expertos intenta ubicar los cuerpos en
un área de 150 metros de largo y 50 de
ancho lo que se trata de hacer ahora es
el descartar la posibilidad de que en
este lugar habrían más restos óseos
humanos carbonizados relacionados a este
caso la posibilidad de que los cuerpos
no aparezcan existe pero los familiares
no pierden la esperanza de encontrar sus
restos y poder llorar los en paz pensar
de que al final de cuentas nunca vas a
encontrarle alguna evidencia alguna
alguna algún cuerpo para cerrar ese
duelo es bien difícil pensar que esa
seriedad se pueden cerrar sin embargo sí
creo yo que hay que hacer los esfuerzos
de alcanzar justicia esta masacre sumó
años de prisión para alberto fujimori
en perú el caso de la cantuta es
considerado como uno de los peores
crímenes contra los derechos humanos en
dos décadas de conflicto interno
hasta aquí esta informativa en france 24
pero los invitamos a visitar nuestra
página web www punto 24 punto com para
seguir la actualización de nuestras
noticias gracias por acompañarnos
continúen con toda nuestra programación
[Música]